kiyong is with us in florida hey kyon
whoops I hit the wrong button there we
go okay hi hi how are you good how are
you better than I deserve what's up I
have a question I'm on babysit too and I
am behind on credit cards I have about
eight of them
we're behind about five three to four
months some among five
should I bring them up to date and then
start paying them in our small ball or
should I just let them charge off and
then pay them and throw the snowball as
well I just don't know what to do and
you're behind five months on some and
two months on others yes three to four
and some and then five on others your
credit will be better if you catch them
up and then pay them off in full if you
let them go all the way into default you
will have more late payments which will
further damage your credit and settling
a credit card for less than full amount
owed also damages your credit now I
don't spend a lot of time wringing my
hands about credit but but it's a good
thing to consider I don't spend my time
destroying and on purpose either so you
know what's the total balance on all of
these cards how much credit card debt do
you have about twenty thousand and what
is your household income we get around
about forty seven hundred a month why
are you behind I ended up getting sick
and so then that's what kind of pushed
us behind I'm back to work again so then
it's just trying to get cut back cut up
mmm okay sometimes you can call them and
do a renovate or rehab on the account
and the conversation would sound like
this if you called the credit card
company say I'm three months behind do
you guys have a program that after I
make two payments that you throw the
third one into the balance and show me
current from then on okay and see if you
can't get them get that account rehabbed
and probably in a couple months you can
get caught up with everybody doing that
I would rather you did that and then
just pay off your balances you're gonna
get there this was not your normal
rhythm of life it was when you got
caught off-guard by an illness correct
and didn't have an emergency fund which
you're gonna build now once you get out
of debt because you're doing our stuff
right yes because we discovered you yeah
I appreciate it I'm glad you're there
hold on I'm gonna send you a copy the
book the Total Money Makeover walk you
exactly through step by step how to do
this stuff but yeah I think in I
generally say let's get current first
now let's change the story for some of
you that are listening let's say she's
eight months behind and it's fifty
thousand dollars in credit card debt
and she makes 47 see you see how those
numbers get just got bigger the amount
she's behind is a lot more than what she
owes is a lot more in ratio to her
income that's gonna make that's gonna be
a long year just to get current then I'm
probably gonna go ahead they're almost
in default anyway I'm gonna let him drop
into default and settle him whenever
that when it's that big a hole but um
you know she's close enough and with her
income and it's not the pattern of her
life she's not someone who doesn't pay
her bills usually she you know it's an
exception she got ill lost her job for
lost work for a little while and so I
think she's gonna be fine don't you
that's why you're listening me too
aren't these folks inspiring I think
they are